here we go hi everyone i'm david
vonderhaar studio design director at
treyarch
welcome to the multiplayer reveal of
call of duty black ops
cold war on behalf of the teams at
treyarch and raven
and all our development partners across
the world
thank you for joining us today we do a
little recon across
all black ops cold war multiplayer the
world
the missions the weapons the characters
and the systems
and you know we'll make some fun
announcements along the way
from here on out we talk directly to you
the best fans in gaming joining me
throughout the show
is a big cast of characters from across
the studio
along with some of your favorite call of
duty content creators and streamers
one thing you've come to expect from a
black ops game is that we are never
quite satisfied with the status quo we
are always looking for a way to do it
better
but some things shouldn't change and for
every multiplayer game we make
one thing hasn't how we start things off
this is the worldwide debut of the black
ops
cold war multiplayer trailer
threat neutralized
you're here because you're the best
special forces nato has to offer
we're all that keeps the world from
turning to cinders comrades
we work off the books operate in the
shadows
to keep the wolves at bay today we
reshape the world
let them calm
foreign
secure
let's do this
[Music]
[Music]
disabled
[Applause]
i'll drive
over here
pre-order digital copy and get early
access to the open beta and instant
access to the woods operator pack in
modern warfare and war zone
you just saw it this is an
unapologetically cold war game
set in the 80s but it's still a black
ops game
and for over a decade we built our
multiplayer experiences
atop a core set of guiding principles
they form our pillars
deniable operations that deploy around
the world
signature combat tailored to how you
play
connected experiences that deliver free
robust ongoing content
and integrate deeply into the next
evolution of war zone
today we're going to explore each of
these facets of multiplayer
we're going to show you how this globe
trotting cinematically connected
experience
is our most immersive yet and then we're
going to show it to you in a way we
never could before
with a little help from some friends
first up the bedrock of black ops
deniable operations these are the places
in multiplayer you never saw
and the things you never did the
missions that stay off the books
and the targets and sources who stay off
the record
the cold war we set out to build is
realistic
it's plausible most importantly it's
inspired by a gritty historical tone
that we've woven into every element of
our game's world and story and gameplay
chaotic and always confidential deniable
ops lie
at the heart of multiplayer raising the
bar while creating a clear and unique
narrative
that influences every bit of our world
building
for black ops cold war that world
building drove each multiplayer level
in two ways with the signature level
design you've come to expect
and by pushing the visual bar and
immersing players into a narrative of
unfolding events
the fight to recover a downed satellite
in the central african desert
battles that unfold on the neon soaked
streets of miami's famed southeast
deniable ops are the black ops stories
inspired by history
but forgotten by the history books
we've selected five maps to give you a
small taste of the range of denial ops
awaiting in multiplayer
later today you'll see them playing but
here's a few of my teammates to share
what they loved most
from how they were made my name is
brittany vitelman
i'm a level designer i'm kendall snow
associate level designer
i'm brittany perello producer i'm matt
senior level designer in satellite a top
secret american recon satellite has lost
power and crashed in the deserts of
angola
with higher dgi forces closing in now
it's a race to secure the crash site
what i love about satellite is the fact
that it's just this amazing natural
space
because larger maps have more components
we can apply more details into maps like
satellite which make them feel even more
natural the satellite at the center is
like a king of the hill
anyone who wants it has to run toward
you because it's raised higher than the
rest of the map
i'm usually playing one of two ways all
in full hand
dying again and again or in objective
modes i'll flank and get the jump on
people
satellite scratches both of those edges
even though it's an outdoor space the
map's two different regions mean i can
play
long and short range tactics i'll be
honest
i am trash with the sniper rifle but a
shotgun
that i can do i have always been a big
fan of close quarters
and there is great cat and mouse style
gameplay in satellite
the crash satellite is a super fun spot
to try and outplay your engines
predict which way they'll circle the
debris to run up behind them or just
duck inside the satellite and take your
shot
this is going to be one of those classic
black ops maps the world knows and loves
for how quickly engagements fire up
east and west collide on the open seas
in a top
secret mission inspired by a real-life
event project azorian
cia jsoc and soviet forces converge to
recover a sunken prototype nuclear
soviet submarine from the ocean floor
calm waters of armada explode into
massive naval conflict
as players battle for control of large
naval vessels with no lanes
walling you in players can engage on
ships decks
in the water and on vehicles like wake
runners and gun boats
armada is chaos in the best way
this really cool map that gives this
amazing sense of exploration there are
so many
little individual areas to find and new
ways to
surround or flank your enemies and get
the upper hand
a hidden safe house has been discovered
right in the heart of the ussr
in the shadow of moscow's opulent train
station
with sped snaps dispatched the area has
gone hot
so the moscow map is set in the dead
heart of a big city
so you're wandering through these
streets with a bunch of cars and there's
tall buildings on either side of you
there's this sense that you've been
dropped into a point in history
first thing i do is run right to the
center because that's where
all lanes cross in the moscow map
and eventually it doesn't take long
people are going to run through
the metro station so you can just sit
there and wait but chances are there's
gonna be people running right into your
line of fire right off the bat
it's a classic three-lane map where
teamwork really makes the dream work
january 17 1984 this location is heavily
influenced by miami's famous
or perhaps infamous ocean drive this is
a night map but one unlike
players have seen before you can sneak
through dark shadowy alleys
go out onto the beach out into the ocean
you can dive in the water
and wait along the coast to get the drop
on the other side
or you can just go right down the street
and bask in the neon light
the first time i played through miami i
could hear this 80s nightclub music
playing through
the walls of one of the buildings little
details make it
lifelike and it becomes this joy to
experience
basically my goal is to never be on the
main street in the center because
that is sniper heaven and that is
britney hell so i always go and try to
flank
and get those snipers from the back
our art and design teams worked really
hard to bring the best possible night
experience to the players
you'll see that play out when you sneak
in the shadows on the beach
or engage enemies in the center strip it
really makes people
feel like they're in miami in the 80s
it's pretty
pretty cool
in crossroads nato has learned a large
soviet missile convoy is on its way to
the border special forces dispatch
alongside
mi6 to ambush the convoy and secure the
weapons before all hell breaks loose
it's one of our most cinematic maps with
a boots on the ground feel that feels
pulled from the campaign your team will
want to hold down and protect its own
outposts to guarantee access to one of
these kinks
but infantry combat doesn't take a back
seat in crossroads as natural terrain
and foliage masks movements
and provides tactical advantages there's
a bunch of snowmobiles when you first
spawn
and it's a mad dash to grab one and now
running people over with the snowmobile
is my favorite thing to do
each environment changes the dynamic of
how you play
and caters to unique loadouts crossroads
is a bigger map
and that allows you to play the way you
want to play
the beaches of miami a frozen over lake
the open ocean
our visual research department racked up
miles visiting them all
because if you're going to deploy around
the globe in this game that required
them to do the same
the mission for our artist is absolute
authenticity
step one in that process is photo
scanning thousands of real world objects
terrains and materials
those assets ensure our upgraded
physically based renderer delivers the
best
looking black ops yet true 4k
high dynamic range with the true color
and tone
ray tracing on systems that support it
photometric lighting courtesy of our
luminaire system
and overhauled contour terrain system
the result is gritty
it's believable i dare say it's got
ambience
most importantly it sets the perfect
stage for multiplayer combat
on that note here's matt with more on
the modes and missions ahead
we've talked a little bit about where
you'll play but let's talk about what
you'll play when you get there
and black ops cold war our classic game
modes are returning and they're better
than ever
from the tried and true team deathmatch
domination
and search and destroy to the return of
the competitive game mode control
we've taken a fresh eye to all of your
favorites
we're encouraging more meaningful
gameplay with larger capture zones and
domination
we're updating spawn systems and
hardpoint and now we show
you where the next hardpoint will spawn
so you can regroup rotate
and set up for the next flight across
all of our classic modes
we're working hard to make this the most
rewarding and competitive multiplayer
experience yet
and while your go-to modes are coming
back better than ever let's talk about
the innovative new modes you'll be going
to next
with that let me introduce you to my
teammate marquise gladney
who's here to tell you about the brand
new multiplayer experience we call
vip escort vip escort began with a
question
how can we create a game mode inspired
by the kind of real-life
totally true but completely redacted
black ops that first inspired this
franchise
the result is extraction in its purest
form
a new 616 objective based game mode we
call
vip escort
in black ops we normally task you with
fighting but vip escort turns that on
its head with a new mechanic
if you're selected as a vip your number
one job it's to live
in this team based op your team will try
to escort you off the map or eliminate
the other team
trying to stop you as vip you'll skip
create a class you're too important
after all
instead you'll deploy with the kitted
out pistol a smoke grenade
a spy plane for team intel and a whole
lot of hope that your team knows what
the hell it's doing
the mission stay alive and escape the
map to do so you'll need to reach one of
two
possible x-fil sites which rotate over
the course of the match to keep teams on
their toes
there are stakes here if you die that
ends the round
but team up and you can get your squad
back on their feet quickly
via last stand and revive
each team's choices and tactics create
layers of strategy
and counter play injecting the best of
black ops themes directly
into this competition will your team
pull cold war mind games and
misdirection
by splitting up the squad to draw fire
and create distractions for the vip
or as a full-on assault more their style
will they travel ahead and scout
run protection detail or take a bullet
for you secret service style
my personal keys to victory i stay close
and escort the vip
and defend them at all costs if the vip
doesn't make it out alive
it won't matter if you do this new
deniable operation only scratches the
surface
of what it means to play cold war
multiplayer
up next we want to share another new way
to play that goes above and beyond that
classic
6v6 experience you've come to expect
combined arms is where multiplayer gets
bigger and better
bringing together the best of
multiplayer's large-scale battles
by combining infantry and vehicular
gameplay into a single cohesive combat
experience
in combined arms domination players will
deploy into 12 versus 12 battles
each customized and unique to its own
environment
but these battles aren't just bigger or
more chaotic we've worked hard to ensure
the two levels of boots on the ground
and all out vehicular warfare complement
and enhance one another on each map
tanks snowmobiles wake runners gun boats
and more
these vehicles amplify the action shore
but they also create
jaw-dropping moments right in the middle
of the fight
the way i personally play combined arms
depends on my mood
if i'm going for the win it's rally time
and i'm pushing to capture every
objective on the map
whether that means loading up a gun boat
on armada or popping smoke so my team
can cross the frozen lake and crossroads
i'm putting my try-hard pants on and
making it happen
and that's the thing in combined arms
almost anything can happen
i'll seek out fun moments that aren't
possible in other modes
like zip lining onto the enemy ship and
seeing how long i can last before
getting taken out
at launch you can expect even more
combined arms maps and modes
each tailored and tuned to bring the
most fun frenetic action this format can
deliver
take armada our most unique map to date
you saw earlier that the only life
preservers on this sea based map are
your tactics as each capture zone
requires a different approach
will you attack surgically with a
two-seater wake runner gather your squad
and storm the main ship
from zip lines that traverse the map to
all new naval tactics
our motto is combine arms domination
realized
bringing high stakes high speed combat
to the high seas
on crossroads you'll trade your wetsuit
for a snowsuit
fighting for control of soviet bunkers
across the frozen tundra
with high power tanks patrolling the
frozen lake and surrounding roads
you'll need to choose how to take on
those slow movers
so whether you're hopping onto a
snowmobile for a quick flank
rolling up your sleeves and sticking on
some c4 story is yours to write in
combined arms domination
that's it for deniable operations for
now we ziplined
cross frozen lakes and dipped into
miami's beaches that's really just the
start of the full deniable ops
experience
add up the work on your favorite classic
game modes to the arrival of new modes
like vip escort
and combined arms domination and it all
stacks up to our most ambitious
multiplayer yet
one you can play any way you want and in
new ways you never expected
if you're a call of duty league fan we
have a bunch of new stuff lined up just
for you
stay tuned this may be a multiplayer
game built for everyone
but these will be your deniable
operations and now i'll turn it over to
tony to talk about what we mean when we
say
signature combat thanks matt now
a lot has changed for us since the first
black ops game from our development
pipelines to totally new technologies
but some things haven't changed and
after over a decade of making black ops
games
we're more inspired than ever to keep
honing in on that authentic
classic black ops feel all while taking
it to new heights
now we know that to you combat is more
than just
pointing and shooting it's about how
your operator moves and weaves through
your surroundings
it's feeling the power of your weapon
how it reacts in your hands
it's the sound of bullets storming past
you the rattle and bang of firing your
weapon
in cold war we're back to plausible
authentic
boots on the ground combat and that has
allowed us to not only refine the feel
of the game
but build on all the classic foundations
of black ops heads up gameplay
automated healing and grounded movement
keeping your player experience in the
front of our minds
has also inspired a fresh wave of
thinking across our created class
and score streak system where we're
introducing features
that bring unprecedented transparency to
your planning
and cinematic wow moments to when you're
playing
now innovating systems while still
capturing that signature black ops super
smooth feel
is a notoriously tricky thing to get
just right and we put
everything we have into it for each game
this is an absolute team effort
so i brought some of my friends from the
combat team to help tell you about our
initiatives for this game
and how they've resulted in signature
combat that feels just right
here's max porter to start us off
we've taken lessons learned from across
black ops and the entire call of duty
franchise to land on a truly
best-in-class weapon experience the gun
is almost always right in front of you
and must look great
from a gun seems down to its grime the
level of detail in black ops cold war
has never been higher
but our weapons also need to move in a
realistic manner
you'll feel it in this game whether
you're clocking from long range
or firing from the hip when we think
about a gun we think about the way it
looks the way it's going to move but a
big part of the gun's personality is the
sound that it makes it's like the bark
of the dog
we're sort of imagining all these guns
as characters
that just adds to that level of realism
and that sort of immersive
quality that is unique to call of duty
it's this multi-faceted approach to how
weapons look animate and sound that
together defines the feel of cold war's
signature gun fighting experience
here's alvin with a debrief on some of
the other combat systems waiting for you
in cold war
let's talk about two of the most
significant and impactful features of
multiplayer
create a class in scorestreaks our goal
with create a class in cold war is to
empower you
without making trade-offs this year
better
starts with simpler create a class will
be a slot based system
no longer governed by allocations or the
picten system you'll always boast
a full class of a primary secondary
lethal tactical field upgrade
and a set of perks field upgrades are
items placed in the world
to give your team an advantage you can
earn them solely based on time
not score and they are the only type of
game content that works on a cooldown
that lasts
after death now wild cards are back
in this system in every class you can
pick one of four wild cards
that let you do things like load your
primary weapon with up to eight
attachments
carry up to six perks double the number
of lethals and tacticals you have
or carry three primary perks from any
mix of categories
of course a key component of create a
class
is the gunsmith
in black ops cold war there are more
optics
and attachments to unlock and configure
than ever before
every primary weapon can be customized
with 54 attachments
across eight different nodes or
attachment points with at least
six options per attach point by default
you can equip
five attachments or eight with the
gunfire wildcard
for the first time gunsmith will show
you what equipping and attachment does
as a positive or negative percentage
you can now build backwards specking out
the perfect gun
for results you want to see in the field
this takes the guesswork
out of the system and helps us on our
never-ending quest
to make the most balanced call of duty
game you've ever played
there's one more thing i need to talk
about first up we've updated scorestreak
so that earned score is kept
through death this change gives all
players a chance to engage with
scorestreaks
one of the most visceral and fun
experiences across multiplayer's
signature content
if you do go on a streak and string
together multiple kills before your own
death
streak score bonuses help you learn into
those higher powered score streak teams
to prevent score streaks span each score
streak will go on a cooldown after it's
used to pace out frequency
so what score streaks are we talking
about well
your favorites are back but we've also
got a few surprises
score streaks in cold war can be used in
all the classic ways
to aid in taking an objective to save
your team
to break up the pace of the game with a
fun new experience
we've also tailored strategy into the
system as scorestreaks can often be
neutralized through the counter school
streak
and now i'll pass it over to sunny to
share more about our operators
and how they move in black ops cold war
[Music]
elites covert powerful when you play as
a cold war operator
you won't just step in the boots of a
highly trained precision instrument
every movement will have a purpose to
increase the fidelity and feel of even
the smallest elements
modelers animators and concept artists
all work
side by side planning for every point of
contact with every gun
every stance and position every scenario
thanks to increased dynamic bone counts
we've been able to enhance the effects
of physics and gravity on what you carry
from the weight of your gear like
pouches and grenades
to the way a wallet chain or rope sways
as you sprint
your entire operator will move more
naturally than ever
here's four specific ways movement has
improved through new cutting edge
techniques in the animation and
programmatic movement
the first is sprint takeoff this is the
feature that gives your operator a
running start
you start with a little sprint and then
it slows down to normal speed
this lets you feel the momentum of like
where you're going and where you're
going to end up
we wanted to preserve the fluidity and
fun of an operator's ability to slide
in black ops cold war when you slide you
start and end in a crouch position in a
believable way
this allows two player movement states
to function better as one
all while improving gameplay enhancing
pace footstep control also plays a big
part of the new movie system
go faster and you'll make more noise of
course we still have ninja as a perk
but ninja is no longer the only way to
keep quiet
whether or not you're crouched how loud
you get is now directly tied to how fast
you're moving
lastly we've incorporated a classic jump
with a much more natural height which
will very briefly slow you down on
landing
our goal in all of these movement
mechanics is to ensure operators actions
are not just authentic but
intuitive when you press a button or a
key you should always feel in control of
your operator
and this system has been built to
translate your decisions into dynamic
movement more seamlessly than ever
the era of the game might be the 80s but
the characters you play will move and
shoot like the world's most highly
skilled operators
signature combat it isn't just how a gun
is shot
it's how that gun feels how it sounds
how it's designed to create a combat
experience and combat
isn't just about conflict it's also a
movement so the fluid ways
in which your operator shift around the
ao and carry the gear you outfit them in
is just as important as the choices you
give them choices like the overhauled
credit class system
were all those attachment possibilities
in gunsmith
or the new ways you can earn and deploy
score streaks in the thick of battle
these combat initiatives work together
to deliver the most intuitive
plausible authentic boots on the ground
experience possible
and they are at the heart of black ops
cold war
on that note i'd like to introduce miles
who's going to discuss some of the
biggest innovations yet
thanks tony all right everyone let's
talk warzone you've seen how we're
pouring it all into the cold war
multiplayer experience
but let's confirm it right here right
now
black ops cold war will also usher in
the next evolution
of call of duty warzone continuing and
expanding the blockbuster battle royale
free to play experience
and it'll be a true evolution with
warzone not merely picking up where the
modern warfare climax left off
narratively
but also interweaving the themes
locations
weapons and vehicles of black ops cold
war right into the action
cold war and war zone will also share
post-launch content
from a narrative standpoint across both
the battle pass system
and item shot content this interlinks
call of duty in ways that evolve the war
zone experience
while delivering jaw-dropping moments so
yeah
you can expect some surprises along the
way
one surprise we're avoiding is the
feeling of starting over
it's important to us that you can still
use your characters
and weapons and progression related
items which is why investment
and progress in cold war is reflected in
war zone
while these are two very big games from
the beginning they've been built to work
together
your player experiences everything to us
so we're making sure black ops cold war
and warzone share progression with much
of your previously earned modern warfare
content
from weapons to cosmetics still
available for use in both war zone
and modern warfare we are collaborating
with our studio partners
across call of duty to preserve
continuity while building a new chapter
of war zone that will immerse you
into all of the best elements of black
ops cold war
that's multiple studios totally
committed to continuing this new
tradition
of insanely fun absurdly accessible war
zone action
we can't wait for you to see how
verdance and all of call of duty will
evolve in the year ahead
but that sense of interconnectedness
extends beyond just warzone
that's why i'm excited to confirm that
black ops cold war
will not only support cross-platform
play and progression
but will also deliver cross-generation
play to the game
that's because black ops cold war is at
its heart
a connected experience and playing
together on whatever platforms you
prefer
only betters that experience cross play
and cross
progression across current and next
generation systems
across all modes that won't be easy but
it's worth it to allow fans who have
never had a chance to play together
to squad up and deploy no barriers
between them
and with the battle pass system
delivering a steady stream
of post-launch content black ops cold
war will be the very first
cross-platform cross-generation call of
duty experience
making it the deepest game in franchise
history
vaughn where do we go next yeah miles on
the subject of platforms we've got a
very special guest
mark hey what's up fam i'm jeff of
binocs we are extremely excited
and proud to bring call of duty black
ops cold war to battle
as the lead pc developer pc continues to
be a critically important pillar of game
development for the call of duty
franchise
in addition to the major improvements we
have made to call of duty pc
in the past including uncapped frame
rates high refresh rate support
and customized field of views we're
always looking for ways to improve
features and customizable settings
one of the biggest improvement this year
is that the black ops engine
now runs on directx 12. this has led to
a huge improvement
in terms of performance and latency
reduction
for players who prioritize immersive
gameplay
we have a great partnership with ndizia
to bring
great race effects performance
accelerating deep learning super
sampling
or dlss and reflex latency optimization
technology we will implement
rate range shadows and ambient occlusion
to improve the quality of
light shadow and sunlight channel this
improves
surface and contact detail and fixes
problems
associated with traditional shadow
mapping techniques
like aliasing freckling and disconnected
channels
also we will be implementing ai power in
the lss
so players will be able to increase
their frame rate while maintaining the
visual quality of the game
for players looking for better
responsiveness we've integrated the
reflex
low latency technology to lower system
related
this combines both gpu and game
optimization
we're also happy to announce that reflex
will be coming to call of duty warzone
in the future we have so much more to
talk about but right now i would like to
end it back to dougie van dar
dan we've declassified a whole lot today
and one thing is clear black ops cold
war is here
and it's ushering in a new chapter of
deniable operations
that are undeniably call of duty at its
very best
realistic plausible gritty
you've seen our team-wide commitment to
storytelling
infusing the story and spirit of the
cold war narrative
into everything we do even in
multiplayer
you've seen our emphasis on authenticity
shine through every location
every weapon every vehicle every
character
each one telling a story we can't wait
for you to uncover and experience
you've seen us challenge ourselves to
not only innovate on classic game modes
but introduce a new generation of
instant classics
modes like vip escort and combined arms
domination
you'll see that duo played today and
it's just the start
as we've got massive drops of free
content planned post launch
including new and limited time modes no
matter what type of multiplayer gamer
you are
you'll find something for you tying it
all together is that signature combat
you love
grounded and always realistic you'll
move fast and fluid
feel powerful when you need to be and
customized
just the way you want to be the new
creative class and scorestreak systems
give you even more of what you love
infusing more control and cinematic
moments with less friction between you
and the gameplay than ever before and
this is a true
connected experience war zone and cold
war
the events in one will impact the events
in the other
expanding call of duty in new ways
you've never seen before
and black ops cold war is not only a
cross-platform game
but it's also a cross-generation
cross-platform game
now that should be the end of our show
but this wouldn't be a black ops
multiplayer review
without some black ops style mind games
we have talked a lot today about what
black ops is how it feels what it does
but for over 10 years black ops is also
something else
a game that consistently presses the
boundaries about what multiplayer means
our team relentlessly looks for
opportunities to offer
new types of multiplayer experiences in
black ops cold war
we're excited to be launching an entire
new category of multiplayer gameplay
called
fire team this new format of multiplayer
brings together everything that we
loved about making cold war and
everything you'll love about
playing cold war across every fire team
mission and mode
you'll discover some of the most
imaginative game loops we have ever
designed
the fire team format allows us to
emphasize teamwork and reward creativity
and it allows you to do things you've
never done in black ops multiplayer
before
you'll fight in squads of four called
fire teams you'll deploy into larger
maps
play fast pushing through multiplayer
objectives and modes that demand quick
thinking
the action won't just affect you but the
environment you battle it
enter fire team dirty bomb one of the
most unique game loops we've ever
imagined
you and your team must search for
uranium then deliver that uranium to
dirty bombs positioned around the mat
deposit uranium and detonate the bomb
now avoid radioactive fallout as you
navigate
a toxic battlefield every decision you
make
impacts your survival rate and your
success rate
we can't wait to tell you even more
about fire team dirty bomb
and the other fire team modes and maps
in the weeks ahead
as we get closer to our public beta i
guess there's only one thing left to do
let's play black ops cold war
[Music]
notorious
[Music]
you're here because you're the best
special forces nato has to offer
you're all that keeps the world from
turning to singers comrades
we work off the books operate in the
shadows
to keep the wolves at bay today we
reshape the world
what the [ __ ] in miami
let them come
big
go go
it's time to punch that top let's do
[Music]
this
ah [ __ ] soviet convoy disabled
i'll drive
over here
now
pre-order digital copy and get early
access to the open beta and instant
access to the woods operator pack in
modern warfare and war zone
[Music]
foreign